pour les commerces la règle est simple
tous les commerces ouvriront à compter
eu on serait la seule exception vous la
connaissez certainement l'occasion d'y
revenir
c'est les restaurants bars cafés sur
lesquels nous prendrons une décision
fera mais c'est tout à fait logique que
les lieux de convivialité seront
associés ensemble on partage un repas au
café c'est à dire sur malheureusement le
virus peut circuler plus facilement
parce qu'on reste longtemps ensemble
fasse l'objet d'un traitement différent
si les pentes où les autres commerces
que ce soit les fleuristes les coiffeurs
et librairies les salons d'esthétique
ils pourront ouvrir à compter du 11 mai
ça suppose ce que chacun travaille
d'arrache-pied sur les guides de bonnes
pratiques
je pense par exemple que sur les
coiffeurs où il ya évidemment et de
proximité le guide de bonnes pratiques
devrait être disponible dès la fin de
cette semaine ce qui permettra à 100
voitures d'ouvrir dans de bonnes
conditions
d'ici le 11 mai votre prêt 11
s'agissant de très grands centres
commerciaux contrairement à ce que j'ai
lu ici ou là le fruit mistral est très
claire ils sont ouverts également le
principe et d'ouverture y compris pour
ceux de plus de 40 mètres carrés
simplement si le préfet estime que ça va
aboutir les déplacements de population
importante une zone de chalandise qui
est très large à 30 40 50 70 km il
pourra ordonner sa fermeture
parce que cela peut provoquer des
mouvements pro important de populaire
loki